[Music]
as the long night comes bearing down on
Westeros almost everyone is heading
north to prepare for the Great War
meaning that most of the characters will
pretty much be on the same place at the
same time with all the main characters
being at Winterfell it only makes sense
for some of them to finally reunite and
share a couple of words John and Danny
with their entire crews are currently
heading north to prepare for the great
war days coming even sooner than
expected
they are sailing towards white Harbor
the main seaport of the north with the
unsullied once they arrive over there
they will meet the track in the Kings
Road and then right to get her to
Winterfell of course all of this so
likely take place of screen and we'll
probably see all of them together
approaching Winterfell in the very
beginning of the first episode once John
arrives at Winterfell he'll have a
heartbreaking reunion with his family
with sensory and brain as well as with
his friends and his direwolf ghost a few
weeks ago John since the reunion has
been even confirmed to take place in the
season 8 premiere with this season 8
first look teaser in which we got to see
a clip of January night amid sister and
Lady of Winterfell Sansa some fans claim
that the hawk cher doesn't feel all that
warm and we should worry about senses
intentions some are even going that far
to claim that this clip prima changed
sense as possible betrayal or Jon Snow
this in my opinion is not the case since
already had an opportunity to work out
Jon in season 7 when the northern Lords
were complaining that the king in the
north should have stayed in North with
Lord Glover and Lord Royce in going that
far to propose censor to take power in
the absence of her brother John we did
not choose you to rule us my lady but
perhaps we should have
the Knights of the Vale came here for
you lady Stark
you are very kind
my Lords but John is our King he is
doing what he thinks is best if she
wanted to a sense of what I've already
betrayed John instead she insisted that
John is their true ruler who is doing
what he believes is right for their
people and that she's merely his Regent
so Sansa betraying John theory is not
plausible at all in my opinion the
reason why sensei might be glaring over
John shoulder could be Danny and there
even may be a tension between Sansa in
John's new lover hearing in mind that
sense of back in the second episode of
the seventh season said that Danny
doesn't want to help north but rather
wants to conquer it many fans are likely
to assume that the stark sisters
including the eternal Lord still not
accept Danny as good as John did but he
might be wrong as Danny said herself in
the season 7 finale she's not hearing
north to conquer it but rather to save
it and that's something the Norton Lords
will see for themselves in the very
beginning of the final season sensible
see for yourself who they initial is and
what her true intentions are and will
without a doubt accept her as the
North's most trusted ally and it's only
hope since I might also stay to John and
Annie they're risking their lives losing
one of the Dragons in order to prove to
Queen Cersei that the army of the dead
Israel was both stupid and pointless
move as beside losing one dragons search
they will never help her own enemies in
the war no matter it's against night
King this is something sense and knows
because out of all of them she's the one
who spent the most time with Cersei and
she's the only one who fully understand
that Cersei will never provide a living
side the troops that she's likely to
lose in the great war and therefore
weaken our position on the Iron Throne
as the queen of the Seven Kingdoms
sensible also warned any that Cersei
will actually take advantage of the war
between the living and the dead which
serves to confirm herself in the season
7 finale animées it's not only John and
Senza who will finally reunite at
Winterfell the next one is a reunion
between John Inari we've been waiting to
see reunion between those two since the
very first season we are be hoping for
John our union in season seven but the
two just missed each other however they
will finally reunite in the first
episode of the final season John loves
and cares for all his siblings by
January have a unique bond which show
made sure to remind us of just before
the actual reunion takes place
lady Stark John left you in charge he
did I hope he comes back soon I remember
how happy he was to see me when he sees
you his heart will probably stop John
and Aria were very close growing up it
was John who secretly had needle forge
for aria encouraging her to become who
she always wanted to be Natalie did that
fester Elsie custom demanded in fact
those two were so close that in Georgia
marks original outline he had them
remarked as lovers it's only fitting for
them to see each other once again before
the great war begins well it's easy to
say that John will be proud but also
blown away by how much Aria has grown as
a fighter it's also safe to say that
area will support John's decision of
bending the knee to the dragon Queen
jungle then reunite with brain as well
it's been a long time since John Simm
brain but brain did see John in season
four when he was travelling north of the
wall he saw John from afar fighting the
meteors to avenge Lord commanders death
brainy's besides a man Howland Reed the
only person who knows John Stehr lineage
and is the only living man who actually
witnessed John's birth even though he's
been waiting the whole season to
revealed to John the truth I don't think
he were real to John in their first
meeting
there isn't being too many people around
him brain and Sammy likely wait for a
private moment with John rather than
reveal it to him in front of everyone
bran might not even be the one to reveal
the truth to John I think it will be
Howland Reed who will in the final
season finally reappeared supporting
House Stark in the living in the war
against the dead the knight King has
brought down the wall in his marching
towards Winterfell while almost all of
Westeros on the other hand is also
marching towards Winterfell to defend it
against the army of the Dead I don't
think he'll Street will be the only
house beside House Lannister not to join
the Great War even though it's possible
that instead of Howland Reed he might
send his daughter Meera to lead small
forces of her house to Winterfell I
think it's time for Howland Reed to
finally appear and play his role anyway
John upon arriving at Winterfell will be
Saturday night in his family jungle all
Surrey night with his friends John and
Samuel see each other for the very first
time since Janice killed and resurrected
Sammy likely real to Jack his show
parentage valhallen will likely finally
appear in the current timeline and
confirmed these same statements to Jon
with some evidence Sam might also know
that John was killed and resurrected
since these two are setting Ravens to
each other but it's not been shown and
therefore we cannot tell for sure if Sam
knows what happened at Castle black if
this is something similar and once he
reunites with his best friend it's
possible they decide willing to Jon that
his
targaryen sand might also proclaim
Jonah's are high in the season 7
premiere the show pointing out that the
bulk gili picked up and began reading
was a book about long night well the
exact part she was reading was about the
prophecy of azor Ahai already made a
video regarding which character might be
this prophesied Savior by John's son of
Ice and Fire seems more and more to be
the Lord's Chosen animates upon finding
out about Joshua parentage in season 7
which basic confirms that his Song of
Ice and Fire and upon finding out about
John's death and resurrection in the
final season it's quite possible that
Sam will proclaim Jonah's were high a
hero that was reborn amid smoke and salt
a hero that will build the flaming sword
to stand against the adults and if he
falls the world falls with him I also
believe that a book about long night
that Gilly was reading in season 7
premiere will resurface in the final
season which would likely attempt once
again as brain if he is able to look
back in time but it's time you further
into the past to see what exactly
happened the last time the White Walkers
came for living this is how Sam and
brain will play a huge role in the final
season as they will help John and Dana
strategize for their fight against the
night king and his army of the Dead this
will most probably involve quite a few
flashbacks where we would learn a bit
more about white walkers and their
motivation now that John's reunited his
family and friends he has one more
important minion to face the one with
his direwolf it's been confirmed that
ghost will finally return in season
eight and one can only say finally we
all enjoyed the dragons but the
direwolves have also been a huge part of
game experience especially of the stark
children we haven't seen ghost ever
since John's resurrection for all we'll
be wondering where girl Stephen is he's
at Winterfell the showrunners confirmed
that ghost remained at Winterfell with
Saint Simon John left to meet Danny a
dragon stone as a matter of fact ghost
was supposed to be in one scene of the
previous season when discussing his
episode Stormborn in season 7 blu-ray
commentary track writer cogman revealed
that he wrote a scene featuring ghosts
but it got cut out we were supposed
seagulls when Jon emerged from
Winterfell crypts right after he
threatened Littlefinger but before he
waved goodbye to Sansa so summer in
their ghost was supposed to finally
reappear cogman provided some more
details there was a bit here where Jon
came out of the crypt and ghost came up
to him and he petted him and said take
care of Sansa watch over her for me but
I guess those dire Wolf's are expensive
I guess it got cut instead of goes the
showrunners decided to fulfill their
long waited wish of having an
barring game adrenals this year made
perfect sense that you could have one of
these things out there and we really put
our our four feet down and we said god
dammit we want the zombie polar bear
anyways the Game of Thrones production
has much higher budget for Season eight
and with that said it only makes sense
for girls to finally reappear Jon will
reign avid ghost early on in the season
and I'm sure we'll see more of him in
the following episodes especially the
battle from Winterfell that is most
likely taking place in episode 3 however
it's not only John who is arriving in
Winterfell and it's not only John who
will reunite to the people he loves and
cares about centering the hunt cocaine
is arriving as well and he'll finally
reunited sense and Arya perhaps the only
two people he cares about his basically
been their only true friend south of
interval the hunt helps sense a lot back
when both of them were in King's Landing
and even offer her to escort her back to
safety which sense unfortunately refused
he also helped her sister Arya trying to
score her back to her family but
unfortunately the red wedding occurred
or a learned great deal from the Hound
and some even claimed that she sometimes
acts like him it's safe to say that the
Hound will be more than proud to see how
far he has become such a great fighter
Arya beside reuniting with John in the
Hound chivalry night with one more
character that is arriving an interval
with John and Danny
it's Kinji the two shared a lot of time
together in the earlier seasons and both
have grown to like and deeply care about
each other they will be happy to see one
another alive and well perhaps the
reunion might even give us a hint or two
that gives us father's promise to arias
fodder in season one might finally be
fulfilled we were meant to rule together
if your sister had lived would have been
bound by blood well it's not too late I
have a son you have a daughter Robert
was talking about Joffrey who he thought
was his son and Ned's daughter Sansa
this never happened and therefore how
stark a house Baratheon haven't been
joined yet however a huge amount of fans
are believing that this marriage might
finally happen in the form of Roberts
only son ginjury and Ned's daughter Arya
having in mind that arias at Winterfell
while Ginji on the other hand is heading
towards it with Jon Snow and Daenerys
Targaryen those two will most certainly
reunite in the final season and it's
going to be interesting to see how the
relationship will play out with the
serious of reunions coming in the final
season one video
would not cover them all I'll probably
make part of this video in the following
days featuring reunions between Tyrion
and sense a Jorah and Sam Jaime and
Tyrion Jaime and Jon and perhaps the
most intense ones the reunions between
Jamie and Danny and between Jamie and
brain and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see you in the next one
peace
[Music]